this song was a smash hit in Europe
satellite was the winning tune at the
2010 Eurovision Song Contest and if
you'd consulted volkmar comets
beforehand he'd likely have predicted
that the Diddy would come out on top I'm
always moved whenever I hear a song like
satellite it has three chords that are
repeated over and over and the sequence
of these three chords is so harmonious
it touches every heart and because we're
so touched I know straight off that this
song will go right to the top in
whatever arrangement rush I these guns
the home come come out systematically
studied what ingredients go into making
a chart topper he took successful pop
songs and looked for similarities in
their melodies chords and rhythms the
results were surprising most of the hit
song studied were based on just three or
four chord progressions krumitz cause
that the hit formula but it is the
interesting thing about these chord
progressions is basically very few new
notes appear so the sounds merged
together the notes keep being used a new
but basically the sound remains the same
take the C major chord with the note C E
and G it's followed by an a minor chord
which also uses C and D these two notes
remain and are joined by a new one the
next chord would be F major where once
again two of the same notes remain
they're not new to the chord own E and F
is added and that's all
a typical example is the Beatles song
let it be composed by Paul McCartney
though it was written nearly half a
century ago the melody is timeless and
catchy it's the major cadence extended
with a minor tonic parallel and when I
play the four chords in sequence in
whatever combination it makes us feel we
just can't get enough of it the other
foot but what makes the songs that use
this formula so successful to answer
that question krotz produce some sound
samples here's the pure version of the
hit formula
and a slightly modified version these
sound samples were played two men and
women ranging in age from 2270 to while
an MRI scanner charted their brain
activity the results showed that the
standard hit formula activated areas of
the brain responsible for feelings of
euphoria and pleasure you can see that
certain areas of the brain become more
active while others aren't activated
anymore looking at the hit formula you
can see here I've activated a
significant area of the brain's reward
center whereas when I eliminate the
formula and remove the rhythm entirely
it triggers an area responsible for
conflict readiness and potential for
aggression so it's a bit like having sex
or eating chocolate each time it arouses
your sensors and feelings of pleasure
renew our brains can be tricked fat
easily find the right chord progressions
that activate the reward center in our
brain and we'll want to hear that tune
again and again and so a hit is born
you